تحدثنا عن هذا اليونانيوم المستنفذ
والانباء عن ارسال قذائف تحتوي عليه
لاوكرانيا لكن ما الفرق بين هذه القذائف
والقذائف التقليديه الاخيره التقليديه
يكون الراس المتفجر لها مليئا بمواد شديده
الانفجار مهما اختلف هدف القذيفه اكان
بهدف التفجير ام الاختراق والتفجير من
الداخل اما اليورينيوم المستنفذ سيستخدم
في تصنيع الذخيره المضاده للدروع التي
تطلق من الدبابات والطائرات قذائف
اليورينيوم المستنفذ يتم استخدامها
بطريقتين الاولى كيمياويه عبر استعمال ما
تسمى بالحشوه الجفاء وتعني تفريغ راس
المقذوف من المواد شديده الانفجار الا من
كميه صغيره من اليورينيوم المستنف يوضع
امامها مخروط من النحاس قبل ان يلمس
المقدوف درع الدبابه تنفجر شحنه المتفجرات
ويتحول مخروط النحاس الى تيار سريع ساخن
من النحاس المنصهر الذي يذيب الدرع وايضا
يخترقه هذه العمليه تعتمد على توليد طاقه
ضغط وحراره كافيه لاعطاب الهدف واختراقه
وايضا تدميره اما الاسلوب الاخر المستعمل
في قذائف اليورينيوم المستنفذ ميكانيكي
يستخدم طاقه الحركه للتدمير كيف يقوم على
الاصطدام المباشر مع الهدف واختراقه يقوم
بتحطيم اجزائه الحيويه من الداخل في هذه
الحاله تتم زياده سرعه المقذوف وكتلته
وقدرته على التماسك ليستطيع اتمام رحلته
داخل الدرع بنجاح من خلال زياده كميه
اليورينيوم المستنفذ كماده قادره على
النفاذ عبر الدروع لكن ماذا عن الاثار
الصحيه لهذه القذائف وهذا امر مهم في حاله
اليورانيوم المستنفذ لا تستطيع الاشعاعات
الصادره منه اختراق جلد الانسان لكن الضرر
يحدث عند وصول الماده الى داخل الجسم عن
طريق الاستن شاق او بلع مواد ملوثه
بالجرانيوم وهنا وصول الماده هذه لداخل
الجسم يمكن ان يزيد بثلاثه اضعاف احتمال
الاصابه بسرطانات الرئه والدم وغيرها كما
ان اليورانيوم يبقى مستقرا في الرئتين وفي
العظام ايضا حتى بعد الوفاه